[Music]
we gotta move the TV drama TV guys
should we say it on three one two three
this is I don't know about doing the big
three years ago I didn't know which one
we were doing we are massive this is us
fans yes guys it is the only network
show nominated in the drama category and
man is it deserving and man is it
exciting to see a brand new show get so
much recognition off the bat these
actors are so excited to be part of this
award show race and it's so fun to
interview them because they're just so
stoked to be there I'm gonna say you can
tell how excited we are but just head
over to et online calm because we have
so much this is us content from reviews
to interviews to their reactions when
they were nominated for Golden Globes
they're nominated for best TV drama and
three stars Mandy Moore Chrissy meds and
sterling sterling k brown are nominated
and they're so excited um but you know
they do have some stiff competition
though yes like you said stiff
competition we've got one of the best
shows I came out of 16 stranger things
the water cooler show of the year for
sure yeah everybody watch that will i
win I don't know I think Winona Ryder
should win in her category though
because she was absolutely amazing in
that so good I'm gonna be honest about
stranger things I got so scared I had to
watch us not watching a couple episodes
just might take um Game of Thrones let's
talk about it a little bit because you
know that's a familiar one in the
category it's the only returning series
nominated in this category the other
four shows our brand spankin new which
is awesome but as we found out Game of
Thrones and I was surprised Game of
Thrones has actually not won the globe
it's been nominated before but has not
won a golden globe for the series not
for the series your Dinklage did win but
yeah the actual series has never won in
that category which is so surprising but
i think this year could be their year I
want it to be their year because it the
last two episodes of the season were the
best i've ever seen on that show battled
the bastards and the winds of winter I
mean that music those scenes uh you know
Tommen's fate spoilers ok I just it was
so breathtaking watching that show and
it wasn't so much gotcha moments as it's
been in the past it was more just like a
beautiful do you see Tory stuck now in
that place where it's competing against
itself you know they're comparing it to
seasons past and maybe when it becomes
that final game of thrones season is one
is we don't really take home all the
statue
use you know what history has shown that
that has happened but I kinda agree with
Ashley like it's kind of hard to ignore
how good this last season was a TV
Academy of course recognized it too so
I'm with you I'm gonna give it to Game
of Thrones but we got to talk about the
brand new HBO show that's also nominated
which is west world if I can real quick
relevant comment from Michael here he
says hoping for a big westworld window
here we go yeah another new show evan
rachel wood as the series lead in that
one and that show man when I first saw
the trailer I couldn't even really
understand what it was about but it has
been a runaway hails oh yeah definitely
and with evan rachel wood like I think
she's a brilliant actress um house had
some acclaim in the past but with this
role in particular she's really starting
to get some attention you want the
critics choice exactly she won the
critics choice and she's not many here
she could take that too I think I think
thandie newton is ax is a big
frontrunner for her category as well
she's in the supporting category for
that show less world got the cash oh
yeah let's both cut the cake um and we
do if I may tease a little bit we've got
a couple interviews with James Marsden
talking about next season and what we
can maybe expect what he's hoping to see
those are up on our website as well all
right should we move into miniseries
because i know we want to talk about the
People vs oj I'm game chance this is a
so funny just to give you a little
background the Golden Globes is the last
possible award show that this show could
win and sweep and i'm pretty sure it's
going to a bestie of miniseries it's got
sarah paulson nominated sterling came
brown as well as courtney be Vance and
um I mean there's no denying that was
such a well acted series and there's a
reason why it's racking up so many
trophies and ignore that she could I
don't think the HFPA is gonna ignore it
either self and what a year for sterling
kate brown between my god and people
versus oj this guy just came out of
nowhere and now we're all seeing his
immense talent and not only a great
dramatic actor but he's been so funny
with us in his interview also you guys
were gonna be with many of the stars of
this is us tomorrow on the bafta awards
season red carpet right before the
Globes so we will put those interviews
up as well but are you guys open for
people forces oj winna let us know I
personally am even though I watched the
night of which is also nominated and
loved it was really great on HBO but
people vs. oj is my pick okay I think
its a sweep I think is a sweep as well
you